teddy au liban poursuite des
négociations aujourd'hui afin d'obtenir
l'exil du général aoun sa femme ses
trois enfants et quelques profs ont
quitté beyrouth et sont arrivés ce matin
en france dans un endroit tenu secret
pour des raisons de sécurité au delà du
général aoun
c'est l'avenir politique du liban qui
est au coeur de tous les entretiens
entretiens qui se sont tenues
aujourd'hui à damas entier et la
nouvelle chaîne seconde tête à tête ce
soir à damas entre le président syrien
hafez al-assad et le président libanais
elias hraoui les deux chefs d'état
examine la situation au liban une
semaine après la défaite du général
chrétien michel aoun le président hraoui
de constituer un nouveau gouvernement
d'entente nationale au liban les
démanteler toutes les mini afin que les
autorités légales reprennent le contrôle
du pays
mais dès cet après midi le chef druze
walid joumblatt s'est refusé de
dissoudre family à moins d'obtenir des
garanties du président syrien
le son côté samir geagea le chef de la
puissante muse des forces libanaises
demandent le départ les prosyriens
entrer dans le m le chrétien il y a une
semaine
mais sur place les syriens semblent
s'installer pour longtemps dans la
région
or après les révélations sur les
massacres de militaires ou de civils si
des le général aoun
la france a demandé au secrétaire
général de l'onu pérenne des polars
d'âge et au liban d'où la montée de
tension entre paris et damas et le
mécontentement des libanais du cigare
soir à l'aéroport de beyrouth
le face à face franco syrien pendant
cinq heures au départ vers paris de
labarthe famille et des proches de
michel aoun
malgré les protestations de
l'ambassadeur de france les soldats
souriants fouiller les bagages et
confisqué quelque 175 mille dollars aux
proches d'aoun michel aoun dont le
gouvernement libanais interdit toujours
le départ afin de le juger pour
détournement de fonds